hey everyone I'm my name is a coupe and
I'm machine learning researcher in a
vast this is my collage who is also
machine learning researcher a novice but
in AI team I'm from Big Data team you
may know us especially the Polish part
of so we're security company and we have
around 400 million customers which means
that we have a lot of data and bad guys
never sleep so there's a lot of data
about botnets malware plenty of such
things
so Mallory analyst cannot by hand sift
through all these things so we're trying
to put as much of machine learning in
our work as we can so we'll just today
briefly talk about what deploying is or
just review it because I guess you
already must know well by now if you
haven't before and then we'll just look
at what the distribution means in this
context why we could need it or why we
don't need it maybe sometimes and then
we will just mention a couple of
frameworks and some approaches that are
commonly used to do distribution in deep
learning so by deep learning we will
think so by deep owning we will usually
mean just having some neurological in
your networks usually large neural
networks because if they are small it
doesn't make sense to do some
distributed deep learning and then we
will talk about optimizing them fast and
scaling them to process a lot of data in
a short amount of time or in a
reasonable amount of time let's say less
than one day or something like that
hopefully well the need for distribution
it rises from the fact that deep neural
networks are fortunately or
unfortunately known for scaling very
well so if you had an infinite amount of
resources for because some companies
have like also kind of infinite amount
amounts of data
I like images from streets or I don't
know some audio recordings of from your
Android phones secretly then you could
probably with infinite resources be able
to process almost infinite amount of
data this is an example of of some
vision tasks where you can see that even
when the order of images goes to
millions the unit will just keep scaling
up and so assuming you can process
millions or even billions of images you
will still keep probably getting better
results so just the motivation behind
distributed deepening and actually like
if you have complicated enough model
without even tuning all the parameters
if you just put more data just will work
better yeah usually fortunately or not I
don't know like the latest trends are
obviously like getting into CPUs and
GPUs in case of Google and of course and
besides that I mean one machine can only
carry so much so many GPUs right so
whenever you have like four GPUs I think
you need to do more you just have to do
distribute it you just have to go
distribute it and like there are a lot
of papers and a lot of research and
actually now probably the vast majority
of research and papers uses distributed
systems for the computations because it
just requires that uses and processes so
much so much data
let's just talk briefly about two
different paradigms of parallelism the
first idea you would probably have is
the data parallelism in which you simply
have let's say four copies of one model
and you have four machines and only
Chilton machines there you have two one
copy of the model and you divide your
training data to four subsets of equal
size or approximately equal size and
then each model or new each machine over
is the say bottle it has the same
weights and then you just feed different
data to each model at the same time and
you somehow need to consolidate the
right updates the gradient
as to actually do the normal stochastic
gradient descent but like in parallel on
let's say four machines so there's two
main approaches of doing it the first
one is the asynchronous approach this
involves having the parameter server or
let's say parameter process which on one
of the machine or on a different machine
and this actually stores stores the
weight of the of the network of the
model and each of the workers or agents
before before each batch receives the
latest weight updates for the center
parameter server sorry the latest weight
the latest numbers basically computed it
the new mini batch and since the
quarians back to the server who in turn
incorporates the new update into into
the central like knowledge into the
central network and then again whenever
another worker asks for the for the
latest weights they they just get it
immediately or the advantage is that
it's fast because the workers don't wait
for each other they just ask any time
and receive new weights anytime but the
problem is that theoretically this can
lead to some problems such as like you
receive some weight you do the update
but in the meantime the server already
is received for example the same update
from a different worker which is just
bad luck and you're like it might slow
down your convergence rate or accuracy
but in practice this turns out to work
pretty well
so it's widely used anything to it the
alternative approach is to use
synchronous training which means after
each mini batch each the workers
synchronized together they synchronize
by averaging the computer gradients and
so the final gradient after each mini
batch is the average of grade of
gradients from each worker now the
problem here is that the let's say the
workers have are like in theory they
should be on average computing probably
and in in the same speed but the slowest
one will sorry the fastest one they will
always have to wait for the slowest
worker in this case and
so this approach is kind of like more
reasonable more safe but unfortunately I
like it slower because the workers have
to wait and if you have a for example
some network this can lead to this
actually being the bottleneck and not
the training itself
another approach completely different
approach is model parallelism this is
kind of a different story because here
so far we assumed that the model can fit
into a single machine if the model
cannot fit into a single machine then
you need to distribute the model itself
the weight it's safe the weight itself
themselves into multiple nose multiple
machines and this is how it can for
example look like right we have four
machines you have like two layers on one
and different parts of the 2000 second
and so on now the problem here is that
this is this is not exactly parallel
distributed by but not parallel but is
the difference between distribution and
parallelism distribution does not mean
that the computation runs in parallel
for example here the computation first
must go through the bottom - let's see
we're going bottom up the computation
must first like complete on the bottom
two machines and only then they send
information to the top machines and when
we go back it is the same story so
basically this is needed if your model
does not fit in into a single machine
but it's slow and like that there is
there is additional cost of course to
community taking communicating between
the machines because the parts of the
model have to share information and I
must we use this for a couple of like
datasets or problems this is just an
example of what we can use it for this
is just a visualization of some
executable file doing some like smart
smart things to visualize the structure
of the file its headers and so on some
and entropy stuff and but this is like
one of the big data that we have and we
can run confirm like convolutional deep
learning stuff in attributed fashion on
these images for example but we mostly I
mentioned model and data problem we well
from now
we're talking about only about data per
ISM because we so far luckily did not
need to use model person because our
models did fit into a single note so far
yeah and we will be mostly talking about
tensorflow and its options because we
just have more experience with JVM stuff
and this is just what we were using and
first way to run distributed training
and tensorflow this is one of the api's
where you when you can easily done it in
a synchronous way so you have to create
as you can see you in a code you can you
have to create first answer for cluster
then on each of the machines you start
instance of tensorflow server you have
to put to the cluster the IPS and ports
of the your parameter servers and your
worker hosts so then you use instead of
normal tensorflow session is monitored
training session where which takes care
of all the communication of the gradient
updates sending them to parameter server
this kind of stuff however as you can
see you have to either by hand put the
addresses of your nodes or you have to
use some other software like mesos yarn
or this kind of stuff if you're lucky
and you're following Google guidelines
to use the highest tensorflow api as
your use case allows you may be using
the estimator api and this is how model
usually can look in there basically it's
super simple all the model description
is in the model function but you have to
be lucky to run it this in the parallel
way there is a new distributed API for
for tensorflow that you just add the
first line which is merge strategy where
transfer automatically finds out the
GPUs on your machine and then it passes
this to run conflict of the old
estimative api and on single machine you
can run it on however GPUs how how many
GPUs you have just with one line of code
and then your model will be distributed
to those GPUs in parallel
this would be synchronous training based
on based on our reduce where all the
gradients are accumulated another option
is all about which is like Python
package from uber that tries to take out
the distribution code from from your
model code you just initialize it you it
works almost as the synchronous
tensorflow that you also have to use
monitor training session however the
only changes that you have to use their
own optimizer and it's actually not that
simple to just wrap your tester file
code for it because you have to use act
actually you have to use it on MPI for
example open MPI which is basically
message passing interface that is like
high performance computing option for
sending messages between the server's
and processes and still it's another
thing you have to configure so it
requires even more knowledge for for you
to run it on multiple machines this also
implements synchronous training usually
also done with all reduce last option we
would like to mention is the tensor
foreign spark which is basically another
thing you can put onto post park and run
your attention for applications its main
advantages that you can run it on
already existing notes if you have
already Hadoop cluster with spark you
just into a couple of libraries on them
and you can run all your tensorflow
programs there which is useful even just
for scoring all your data set because in
many cases your data will not fit into
single machine or even couple of
machines for on the specific cluster it
will still live on the Hadoop cluster
it has two working modes basically first
one in SPARC reads the data itself and
passes it in memory to test for program
another option the tensorflow program is
started in the side of SPARC executors
and reads data from HDFS and with the
SPARC tensorflow connector you can
actually store your spark data frames as
a tensor flow records which will speed
things up even more how does it look
actually this is just the code you need
for tests of
spark it's pretty simple however all
your model has to be inside of the map
function where you import tensor flow we
create your own model and it's basically
if you haven't already distributed and
servo program to run it on spark you
just import answer for one spark and add
two or three lines of code and it should
work in this case Park will take care of
all the communication between the nodes
all the assignments of the devices this
kind of things just to quickly compare
it if you can just use the tensor flow
with distributed strategy API it will be
just single node but if you have a GPUs
on one single node it's still fine and
it's really the one line of code and it
it works the hoarder work for us seemed
a bit slower because since it's the
synchronous and it requires quite a lot
from the network and we had our GPU
servers in multiple places it didn't
work that well
Tennessee Florence Park was great
because you can run it on an existing
Hadoop so even if you just train your
model separately you can just call all
your data in the Hadoop and a
synchronous tensorflow scaled pretty
nicely it was fast just as many GPUs you
add the faster in your data processing
yes and it's actually kinda easy to
write
so I Indian like why you may not really
need the distributed version that you
split your training into multiple
machines and multiple devices is that we
are still not at the limits of the
computation and single node for for for
the GPUs with tensor cores with 16 point
precision it just still works on single
machine plus with the GPUs you can run
it in a cloud even faster still the
changes to make it distributed require
some code which is not always easy to
properly write and configure the main
thing though is that you most probably
will not need that complicated models
the simpler models are enough and there
are much more data efficient so you
don't need that much data so you don't
need to distribute it on the other hand
you can also
then the question arises what actually
is distributed learning and what is not
or distributed deep learning because for
example if you're trying to come up with
a reasonable solution what you may do
suppose you have like for GPU servers it
may be more efficient to just write a
very simple script that will run a
different optimizer on each of the four
machines or it will run it will do the
hyper parameter search on each of the
four machines separately right so that's
kind of distributed but like not by the
actual definition of disability planning
where it means that you like one
training process is it's across like
wanted multiple nodes what you can often
do have what is probably even better for
experimentation is to simply run
different models on different nodes and
it's like because typically we still
need to do some hyper perimeter search
and if you have multiple nodes it's
probably a good idea to to paralyze at
least this this stage of development
although we did not consider this as
distributed deep learning Thanks that's
all for us we had to do it pretty fast
because we have a plane to catch for if
you have any questions feel free to
write us thank you thank you
[Applause]
okay let's move swim it smoothly to the
ignite talks I think the first person is
Mario on the list
do you have Mario Trammell here nope
okay so Christopher Nowinski he was here
a minute ago
all right let me check was the third
person I just remembered
- mmm Bobby dramatic okay do you have a
laptop you want to show something okay
because so who plays the bridge this
card a captain who plays the bridge
not much do we have any enthusiasm of a
bridge that it's watching the breaching
breeched videos on YouTube and
transmissions analyzing the cards and so
on is there anybody any one person that
does such things yeah good for you my
colleague and I during the studies he's
a bridge world master developed come up
with a problem that on which tournament
there are people who are sitting next to
the table and they often don't know
anything about the bridge so they are
sitting and watching the people who are
playing and this putting into the
internet cars that were played and our
idea was to create a solution that we
can take this card game and
have it flawless or more lovely than it
was before because those percent
sometimes very often makes mistakes and
people who are enthusiastic in bridge
they basically are upset about poor
quality of the transcription of the
bridge and as you know all know that
which is very exciting so we don't want
to spoil the fun for those people so our
solution was to buy Raspberry Pi connect
to simple web camera and on the
tournament between bridge players is a
porter so on the border you can place
the camera cameras and Raspberry Pi with
single energy source and them starts to
read the both have other tables because
this is a place with a game with
partners and they do not need to see
each other because well I can blink an
eye and say oh I've got four aces so
that will be cheating and simply we
found the algorithm that is using the
Aleks net that classifies the cars that
are already on the table and it's not
quite simple because we need to firstly
be resistant to all conditions like
different contrast lights and so on so
it just done the simply threshold truth
holding but it was adaptive then sent
those thresholded images to the server
which with the sliding window cutting
out the 60 by 60 pixels and resizing it
to the 224 by 224 for Alex net and
pushing it through the Alex net we get
precise classification of the cards that
were played on the table but in bridge
is one specific person this person
when the licit ation comes over is
putting all cards on the table and
serving it to the partner because the
partner is the player who plays also
those cards and there is another problem
that needs to be solved in such a system
because all cards are visible so in we
constantly need to monitor what cars
were visible from the scratch from the
beginning of the game and when the cars
is disappearing it's it's thought that
it's it was played and then when four
cars were played from four different
people we know that the one round was
completed and there is one assumption
that we know the cars of the players
because on tournament andris tournaments
and each each pair is each table is
playing the same set of cards so
previously they are defined and we have
access to those and this is our simple
solution that for those little world of
bridge enthusiasm we can make the life
easier
[Applause]
I think do you have questions to David
for that anything you can catch them up
to afterwards like alright thank you so
much
another speaker hold on we can set it up
hold on it works
you'd have to stick to five minutes just
yeah you can go smoothly like slowly so
everyone can get it okay
so Christopher Nowinski I'm a late
talker hello today I'll be presenting
Python links info it has the best Python
videos from the best Python conferences
currently 822 Python videos the problem
it solves is if you go to youtube and
you search on Python the second one is
four years old
pythons changed a lot since then the
third one is on Monty Python the first
one is it's really good training but
it's four hours and a half so on my
website when you go there I have a time
index so you can find it and the fourth
one is also a very good talk on both our
sites if you go to PI video org they
have over 14,000 videos but they go back
to 2008 some are really out of date they
have over 2000 tags if you can find your
tag you can click into it but they don't
sort which is the best one when you come
to Python links tot info on the home
page you can see the 10 best talks the
ranked by upvotes versus total votes you
can see they all have perfect scores
they don't have any down votes that's
why they're the best talks if you click
into a particular video you can see the
video you can see the conference
description often I have to pull the
conference description and on with the
website sometimes I can find the links
to the talks sometimes I have to delete
junk that's that's in them the rest of
the website is organized as a tree of
categories for any branch of the website
you can see the best videos in that
category you can also see the last list
view here we have iff right here um here
we have the two sub cubic sub categories
machine learning data science
parallelism Python and people this
includes how to run open source project
organizations management job seekers a
whole section on Python skills beginner
advanced Python software and it's all
organized as a tree so when you go to
the desktop version
top dot Python links info you can see
this whole graph of the tree the root of
the tree is in the middle it's
JavaScript it's really fast you can
hover over it with your mouse and and
browse the tree here you see the best
talk from last year's PI data Warsaw and
the indentation tells you where you are
in the tree it was on tensor traffic we
can click into the conference and we can
see the ten best talks at last year's PI
data Warsaw very soon I'll have the
votes up for this year's talks on PI
data Warsaw but there's a difference
between the votes and what people
recommend so if you send me your
personal recommendations I'll put that
in and the results will be a bit
different
you can search when you search on a
Python conference you see all the talks
in that conference but it's much more
useful to search on something like data
science software and there's a category
there no talks ever call themselves data
science software but there is such a
category and you can click into that
category and you can see here this is
not the best view this is the list view
because your interest in software you
interested in some particular library
and then you can go into that branch of
the tree and see the best videos on that
particular software package so I do all
of this on a graph stored in an object
database written in Python it's really
easy for me to do calculations on trees
if I tried to do this on top of a
relational database for every node in
the tree I would have to do a join
across multiple tables if I tried to do
this in pandas well pandas have a
statically bound parent pointer but I'm
using an array of dynamically bound
child pointers so it's really good to
use a graph of object database written
in Python really easy and I also do
calculations on the tree on the JSON
tree in JavaScript on the client I'm
looking for people to help me with this
now it's quite mature I do a pretty good
job of sorting them but I'm not an
expert in any particular library what I
need to do is work with the open source
libraries to make sure we have all the
best videos in that particular cat
great that's starting to happen so if
you'd like to help with a particular
library I'd love to talk to you you can
go to the website you can click on the
menu and you can receive updates and
what new conference comes in I'll send
you in a new conferences index tells let
you know I invite you to follow me on
Twitter at Python links the menu option
also has the menu option also has a
contact information if you go to Twitter
you can upload you can retweet some of
the tweets there's of one of the I think
it's the fourth tweet links to the pull
request on github for awesome Python
thank you very much I have some business
cards and flyers I'll hand out to
[Applause]